that it had me hysterical I was crying
like I have not laughed this hard in a
[ __ ] minute dude the caption for this
so this is a this is like understand
this is buhdeuce here all day boy dude
[ __ ] I'm just trying to get it to the
beginning so this is a screen recording
of a girl going through her messages on
facebook and this dude is leaving her
voice memos like I supposed to typing
the caption on this is if your [ __ ]
gonna have me like this please put it on
me bro no matter what oh my god from
crying cuz this girl was gonna dump his
ass play that again I gotta here like I
was you no matter what damn you got a
crying hard to almost people dude her
[ __ ] message is so funny
can you [ __ ] stop dude this is not
love at all imagine almost throwing up
because a girl was gonna leave you man
that [ __ ] five-year-old [ __ ] at the
end when he's like six-year-old crying
oh my god dude I couldn't believe that
man I just kept picturing this dude in
his car like screaming at his phone and
then getting to the puke part and still
hitting Sam like I didn't didn't think
that would be a loss of character just
know she has to hear me frantic that's
pretty funny
frantic feel like that's that's
something that like babies and dogs do
yeah like holy doing something so hard
that he's a mother bodily function yeah
really realize it and they just just
push past it